hi
hey reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name good sir my name is
Harry Howard and I'm also a reject
that's right today he is a reject Harry
Howard you could follow this guy on
Instagram I met him at the premiere of
fury of the fist lauren francesca
introduced us to each other she did and
then i went on his talk show on the
focused TV network the hashtag harry and
kelly if you guys haven't seen it i'm
gonna put a link in the description box
of launching to the youtube link that
way it's much easier for you to find
focus TV network is this awesome website
full of a bunch of talk shows on there
and i had a great time and in the middle
i had interviews like Harry you got to
come on the channel and ours is comedy
there shows comedy yeah he left and so
if I laughed it must mean it's funny
because clearly I don't laugh at most
things he's a tough critic I'm a tough
critic I'm a tough cookie this one I'm
so happy you're here I'm beyond stoked
he is like the younger more evil version
looking of Tom Cruise and that's what I
like having risky business right here
there's a requested video class a comedy
right here top fifty painful moments
good
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is the point of that this is like
jackass but it's not on purpose
he's dead you see that he's talking
noise I think
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't swim in the water here in
Blackrock until today
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you could break your pins like yeah do
you think a lot of these people in the
hospital
[Music]
waiting for it that was not one of the
baby Jesus you kicked the baby dude
that's messed up man Oh
what is he doing is he jerking off went
to the hospital
oh for sure
[Music]
so many children are broken
Amit snap back in oh that was ridiculous
[Music]
this is supposed to be safe this is like
what she was supposed to
the midsection of Angela laughing at him
that hurts hope that he's okay so
Russell still down we'll check on him
[Music]
we're back to here it is the worst one
or something
we're on number 40 okay I mean a lot of
that was no no please no okay oh I
thought we're gonna hit the Rhino in the
Netherlands a cyclist is taken down by a
spectator wow that's really give up and
cross to the finish line she is being
treated for a broken car they arrest
that person you ran away probably was a
guy this is messed up
[Music]
oh my god he got hit by a car smarter
than that did stand by a little girl
what is this white oh oh yeah he's out
he's out cold there
glass wall his whole face is bruised
what could happen here
you're proposed hi hello sorry to stop
your shopping act and your evening hello
I just have a very special message for a
very special girl this is maybe made
this is maybe first saw each other this
is where I fell in love with you and you
my absolute John and you had me that day
at hello when you say hello to me I mean
I'm sure I said hello anyway you're
mighty on who you're my sweetie pie you
might be honest I know you find this
cheesy but but I want everyone to talk
you make me really happy and have a
little poll when you smile superstone
stares for a while and my heart ceases
to beat and there's nothing else that I
seen except you
and I just have one question for you you
truly make me the happiest person on oh
[Laughter]
my god for a second I was like that's
not the most physically painful one out
of the compilation but I could also see
why they capped it off without one thing
was caught doing something before that
yeah oh no he was trying to make amends
for something he must have messed up or
something and he was gonna propose like
I can't lose this girl after some
mistake this is the most uncomfortable
proposal I've ever seen I'm so mad at
him aren't you so mad
the entire time she was not smiling the
funniest one and worst one was when they
were breakdancing with the baby
crack me up honestly sometimes I watch
these compilations and I don't watch too
many of these because most of the time
they don't live up to its title majority
of that was excruciating she them
cracked their bone just from the very
beginning with the with the couple who
just got married my favorite ones are
when they're not only embarrassingly
painfully awkward but also physically
painful oh my god like with a couple at
the beginning yes we just got married a
lot of this is like America's Funniest
Home Videos yes it's way worse people
getting hit in the crotch it's way more
hardcore though have you ever had a
painfully getting hit in the crotch
moment in your life one that really
stands out to you oh I chose to forget
about it okay I didn't learn how to ride
a bike until very late in my life I'm
talking like night club okay way later
yeah way later when I was about 17
actually my friend who lived in Valencia
the mountains of Santa Clarita we were
really hungry and none of us had a car
at the time so he was like dude let's
just take a bike down to Albertsons and
we'll grab some lunch apples and I was
like that sounds like a great idea I
didn't know how to ride a bike so he
quickly taught me how to ride a bike I
started getting the hang of it then we
were biking there's little light like
street lights on the on the actual
street I hit it the handlebars
turned like that and for some reason
physics just decided to go out the
window and apply very differently to man
mode I didn't go like that I went up and
then I went straight down there right on
there yeah and then I had to crawl to
this sidewalk yeah and I was like
Brandon go get the Lunchables these
people had their first circumcision a
lot of these I'm like how did you not
die from this or any other college this
one is so unrealistic because a tree
hits him on the head and then they get
up that's what I loved about the
reaction it was a little painful wasn't
it it was slightly painful right there
yeah and it's a tree falling on their
head I think the last one it has to be I
mean yeah and this one doesn't make
sense cuz there's so much color so I was
getting mad because thought the prank
would have been he wasn't going to
propose yeah but she was getting mad
because he was gonna propose I thought
she was getting mad because he wasn't
proposed right and I love the thought
process too
she's like I can't stop him I just got
never seen that and they knocked out the
Bellas so garrison he could sue her he
has physical evidence for yeah yeah
domestic violence physical that one
that's not funny there's some serious
other some of these things aren't funny
they're just oh yeah I didn't laugh they
were saying this was female cyclists and
then he just thought it'd be funny to
stick his hand out and knock this girl
over Beth she broke her collarbone
although sometimes what I am in the car
I do imagine doing that too like if I'm
in traffic just like sticking on a
motorcycle guy just talking about okay
that'd be a really funny thing to do to
someone or just like throwing a can of
Pepsi at that moment so make sure
yeah exactly that really lived up to the
hype there right it really that really
was too painful i was pleasently it was
funny and also heartbreaking right yeah
and the tree one I can't believe those
girls just said oh wow hey guys can you
once you leave down in the comments a
really painful moment you've experienced
I'm talking emotionally painful
none of that physical stuff just go with
like when someone cheated on you when
you cheated feel guilty when a family
member died those are the funny ones
right there put them in the comment
boxes below and my circumcision when I
was three months old wasn't nearly as
painful as their circumcisions Wow oh
but I thought your way did you wish
people get it circumcised the three
months old yeah maybe it's like one
month old forget with him immediately I
don't remember no I'm not Jewish I don't
act like I don't remember the pain but I
just did it myself on your bicycle yeah
that's what it happened yeah sure you
Wow class a car D right
[Applause]
Mary how're the o0 subscriber the reject
nation click that notification Bell link
in the description box for my interview
with Harry and and Ren actually even
though it's Harry and Kelly Ren was
substituted that day I got an idea I got
a better on yeah Jo or else you'll be
rejected those are those joke they don't
do that here just your hashtag jokes
jokes